and this is where we start this morning
the White House and many state governors
are clashing on two fronts today over
the coronavirus testing and went to ease
a lock downs over the weekend America
surpassed 759 thousand reported cases of
this virus
the reported nationwide death toll is
now more than 40,000 and that's nearly
double what it was a week ago yeah
despite those terrible numbers gale the
economic strain is driving some
Americans to protest stay at home orders
but there are questions about how the
rallies consisting largely of the
president's supporters were organized
and well before kiss is in Miami Manny
we understand Florida is already moving
to reopen non-essential businesses
that's right Anthony some Florida
beaches are slowly starting to reopen as
the state considers how it will get
businesses here back up and running
let's show you some time-lapse video
from Saturday it shows people flocking
to a Jacksonville Florida Beach after it
reopened but Florida like many other
states has seen its kovat cases increase
up more than 34 percent in the past week
many of those protesters across the
country say for them this is about civil
liberties but at the end of the day a
lot of it is also about jobs and as the
lockdowns linger the demonstrations
continue to grow in San Diego
demonstrators showed up waving flags
holding signs voicing the same demands
at 19 we all need to get back to work
and with no social distancing in sight
protestors in Wisconsin numbered in the
hundreds and had a united message and
the lockdown now in Denver Colorado
yesterday demonstrators swarmed the
State Capitol building an apparent
counter protester dressed in scrubs
blocked cars by standing in the street
and in Texas which is set to start
reopening state parks today with some
businesses partially reopening Friday
people ignored social distancing to
demonstrate president Trump weighed in
on the protests during his Sunday White
House briefing people feel that way I
watch the protest and they were all 6
feet apart it was a very orderly group
of people although must vocal it still
appears the majority of Americans are
not in a rush to lift stay at home
orders a new poll from the Pew Research
Center showed 66 percent of Americans
say they're afraid of social distancing
measures ending too early including a
majority of both Democrats and
Republicans
after ravaging cities cases of kovat 19
are spiking in rural parts of the
country
Oklahoma saw nearly 32 percent increase
in the last week
Arkansas more than 39% in the same time
frame there was a more than 82 percent
jump in Iowa the state saw its largest
single-day increase on Sunday with most
of those cases from workers at meat
processing plants and South Dakota side
of the shuttered Smithfield pork plant
saw a jump in cases of nearly 124
percent last week former FDA
Commissioner dr. Scott Gottlieb on Face
the Nation yesterday says the crisis
especially in areas outside major cities
is far from over
you see these super spreader situations
as you saw in South Dakota Dakota so I
don't think anyone's out of the woods
right now some of those anti quarantine
protests are possibly being organized by
conservative pro-gun activists Facebook
tells us that unless the government
prohibits those events it will continue
to allow them to be organized on
Facebook Tony still very small protests
in the scope of the very large country
Manny thank you very much